معهد الزلازل التركي في جامعه البوسفور ان
هزه ارتداديه بقوه 4.5 درجات على مقياس
مقياس ريختر ضرب ولايه ديار بكر جنوب
تركيا كما اعلنت اداره الكوارث والطوارئ
التركيه ان هزه ارضيه بقوه 4.1 ضربت ناحيه
البيستان في محافظه كهرمان مراش صباح
اليوم وكانت الاداره قد اعلنت ارتفاع
اجمالي عدد قتل الزلزال الى
42,310 من جهته اعلن والهاتاي ارتفاع عدد
ضحايا الزلزلين اللذين ضرب الولايه الى
سته قتلى ونحو 300 جريحه واخرجت فرق البحث
وانقاذ امس جثامنه ثلاثه مواطنين من تحت
الانقاض قضوا خلال محاولتهم اخراج اغراض
من منزلهم المتضرر من الزلزال السابق
الان اذا بدنا انقره مراسله الجزيره فرح
الزمن شوقي لتوافينا باخر التحديثات خصوصا
بعد الانباء عن هزات ارتداديه ان كان في
ديار بكر او في كهرمان مرش
نعم ازدهار في الحقيقه هذا هو ابرز ما
يحصل استمرار الهزات الارتداديه ومنها ما
يعتبر هزات قويه وشديده وتزيد المخاوف مع
استمرار هذه الهزات لماذا لان هنالك عدد
كبير من الابنيه المتضرره والمتصدعه والتي
يزداد ضررها ويزيد مع ذلك احتمال
سقوطها وهو ما قد يؤدي الى اصابات جديده
بعد ان اعلنت افات ضروره او جددت تحذير
التحذيرات من ضروره عدم الاقتراب من هذه
المباني حتى المباني التي تمت معاينتها في
وقت سابق وتم التاكيد بانها قابله للسكن
والتي عاد اليها مواطنوها في وقت سابق
اصبحت في الحقيقه ايضا مهدده بسبب تكرار
هذه الهزات الارتداديه افات تتحدث عن هزه
ارتداديه كل ثلاث دقائق تقريبا وحين مر
على الزلزال ثلاثه الزلزال اول زلزال ك 13
يوما قالت ان عدد الهزات الارتداديه في
هذه الايام الثلاثه عشر يعادل هزات
ارتداديه تقع في العاده في اربعه اشهر
ولكنها في العاده تكون منخفضه للغايه اذا
هذا هو التحدي الابرز في هذه المرحله وهو
استمرار الهزات الارتداديه عدد القتلى في
زلزال كهرمان مرعش الذي تجاوز
42,000 يضاف اليهم سته قتله سقطوا خلال
الزلزالين اللذين وقعا في دفنه
وسمنداف اول امس وزاد معهم عدد الجرحى
كذلك وهو في الحقيقه ما يزيد التحديات لكن
الان مع استمرار اعمال رفع الانقاض
وانتشال الجثث ماء ما ان كان بالفعل هنالك
المزيد من العالقين تحت الانقاض وهو امر
لم تؤكد عليه افاد حتى اللحظه الايواء
والاجلاء ما زال مستمرا في هذه المرحله
افاد من ناحيتها تتحدث الان عن اجلاء نحو
نصف مليون شخص تقريبا من تلك المناطق هناك
اخرون غادروا بارادتهم نحو مدن اخرى ومنهم
من يعيشوا في فنادق او شقق او في المدارس
لكن ايضا مساله الايواء الان عدد الخيام
التي نصبت في المناطق المنكوبه حتى الان
تجاوز 300 الف ولكن الهلال الاحمر التركي
الذي ينتج هنا في انقره ما يعادل 500 خيمه
يوميه يوميا ما زال يؤكد الحاجه الى انتاج
المزيد من الخيام الى ارسال المزيد من
الخيام لا سيما مع تكرار الهزات
الارتداديه ووجود حاله من الهلع والذعر
لدى المواطنين حتى ممن تم الاعلان او
تاكيد بان منازلهم ليست متضرره اذا اجلاء
اكثر من نصف مليون شخص ايواء في الخيام
300 الف تقريبا وهذه الاعداد في الحقيقه
ازدهار مرجحه لان ترتفع مع استمرار الهزات
الارتداديه شكرا جزيلا لك
مراسله الجزيره فرح الزمان شوقي